let's talk about the hidden Factor okay
a vitamin deficiency
in numb hands or pins and needles in
your hands or your feet okay a lot of
people have this they might even have
carpal tunnel syndrome and there's a
hidden cause for it and I want to talk
about it but I first want to kind of
give you some definitions of some words
that might be new the first term is
myelin myelin myelin is the coating
around the nervous system it allows the
nerve impulses to travel and without
this myelin you're going to have a short
circuit in the electrical system and you
can get all sorts of what's called
paresthesia which means abnormal
sensation and paresthesia could be a
combination of numbness tingling pins
and needles cold hot burning pain can
come from a lack of myelin on your
nervous system or your spine final
column okay and the medical term for
that is demyelination the removal of
this myelin sheath around the nervous
system now and there's another term I
want to introduce you to and that's
called myelopathy Okay what's myelopathy
myelopathy if you break it down Milo
meaning spinal cord and pathy meaning
suffering okay so your spinal cord is
suffering you know from various reasons
and one reason is the myelin sheath is
breaking down and when that myelin
sheath breaks down you start feeling
Sensations in your hands and your feet
one cause of this could be diabetes okay
where you have the loss of the smile and
sheath because your sugar is too high
and that's usually a deficiency of
thymine okay because thymine is also
involved in making the myelin and so you
would just take more thiamine and change
your diet and that problem would greatly
improve and that usually happens in your
feet first okay not necessarily in the
hands but it can happen in the hands but
it's mainly in the bottom of the feet
but if it's in the hands one cause of
this breakdown in myelin is a vitamin
B12 deficiency it's actually quite
common a lot of people are not getting
enough B12 and that's why I'm doing this
video right now to bring up your
awareness and make this connection
between a symptom that I probably
haven't talked about very much and that
is the loss of myelin in the cervical
spine in your neck that's where it can
commonly occur so you can even see this
degeneration in the spinal column on an
MRI
and the various parts of the spinal
column can then relate to problems that
happen down the arm into the fingertips
a B12 deficiency can also give you other
symptoms as well that might not be as
common like your gait when you walk you
can feel like you're out of balance
almost like you drink some alcohol which
when you really didn't drink any alcohol
you're shuffling along this problem in
the smaller column in your neck from the
B12 deficiency
can also show up in other parts of your
body it can show up as urinary retention
bladder problems
you can have bladder problems from a
problem in your neck interesting you can
have problems in your feet like the
numbness the paresthesia from a problem
in your neck
you can even press your head down Flex
it down like this and cause shooting
pain down your spine just from this the
myelin sheath missing in your neck and
of course you can have a lot of
stiffness in your neck as well and
another reason I'm bringing this up is
as we age okay we lose
stomach acid okay and when we lose
stomach acid we cannot absorb B12 and so
a lot of people that are older have a
B12 deficiency and they also have a lot
of neurological issues too with their
fingers and they also have a lot of
degeneration and pain in their neck too
if you take an x-ray of their spine in
the neck you'll see that there's a lot
of breakdown here and some of that
degeneration at least on an MRI could be
coming from a B12 deficiency on top of a
pre-existing injury and things like that
if you don't know that
you know let's say you get surgery for
your neck and you still have a problem
or you get some type of therapy for the
pain and you still have a problem why
because you haven't made this link
between B12 and the myelin sheath so now
let's complete the list of why someone
is low in B12
is it just because they're not consuming
in that B12 that could be maybe they're
a vegan or a vegetarian and they don't
eat animal products B12 is very high in
animal products right you have the the
beef the lamb the pork the chicken organ
Meats for sure it's in Fish seafood
shellfish it's also an eggs cheese and
so if someone doesn't eat those Foods
then they need to take B12 as a
supplement and I'm going to tell you
exactly what type of B12 you should get
in a minute but I just want to kind of
go through the list another really
common cause of low B12 is the person's
stomach acid is just not very strong
they're losing the acidity in the
stomach and this happens as we age
the great majority of people over the
age of 60 70 and especially 80 are very
low in stomach acid so they're not
getting the benefit of the acid to
stimulate this B12 and the B12 just
doesn't get absorbed that well if you
are older
and you have this numbness or tingling
in your hands you should be taking
something called betaine hydrochloride
it's a natural supplement you take maybe
three four five six of these little
tablets before a meal and you're going
to start to acidify the stomach and
you're going to start to absorb B12 and
another I have in the list is antacids
if you're taking antacid that could be
the reason why you don't have enough
acid in your stomach and that's going to
create a problem so you're going to have
to figure out what to do about that I
put a link Down Below on
a solution for that and to solve the
real reason why you need an antacid in
the first place all right taking
metformin metformin has one side effect
of lactic acidosis and that occurs when
someone does not have enough B12 and B1
metformin depletes your B12 and it also
depletes vitamin B1 so if you're on
Metformin chances are you need more B12
and that could be the reason why you
have this symptom in your hands another
common reason for a B12 deficiency is a
genetic reason there is a new thing with
genetic testing nowadays you can go get
your DNA tested and find out what
weaknesses you have so you can support
those fairly well-known Gene that a lot
of people have a problem with is
MTHFR okay that's the name of a gene
that has to do with
folate and this also relates to B12 and
the right kind to make it all work and
if you have this problem with this Gene
which by the way 30 of the population
has then you're going to be deficient in
not just folate but B12 as well because
your body is our difficult time
absorbing B12 on top of all these other
factors okay and that can show up in
many different ways in one being
numbness or tingling in the fingertips
another reason why you might have a
deficiency of B12 is just that you can't
absorb it because either you have
inflammation in your stomach
or your small intestine or large
intestine you have irritable bowel
syndrome or you have some type of past
damage from that that could be the
reason why you're not absorbing B12 and
then the last reason would be that you
had gastric bypass right which you're
altering some of the small intestine in
the stomach to the point where you can't
you don't have that surface to absorb
the B12 anymore and then all of a sudden
one day you're going to put these these
weird sensation in your wrist or your
hands well it's coming from a B12
deficiency okay so what is the solution
well to take the right form of B12 you
may need to go beyond just eating foods
high in B12 you might need to need to
take it as a supplement so the type of
supplement that you want to take to
resolve this paresthesia in the in the
hands or even the feet would be
methylcobolamine okay methylcobolamine
not the
cyanocobolamine version but the
methylcobolamine version if you have
this genetic problem like I mentioned
you also want to get a product with
methylcobolamine and methylfolate which
is the right kind of folate with B6
that's the remnant you can get all these
in just one supplement okay you start
taking that and you're going to know
some great improvements if you are a
diabetic okay or have a pre-diabetic and
you have this problem uh in your hands
or your feet okay you might benefit more
from a fat soluble version of vitamin B1
and that's called benphotamine and
photamine is wonderful to help this
myelin sheath problem mainly in the feet
but also can help in the hands as well
so anyway I wanted to bring up this
connection that may be helpful
especially if you have the problems I
just talked about to give you more
information about this common genetic
problem that I just mentioned MTHFR I
put that video up right here check it
out